[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العنويه
وصفه هجوم من روسيه لا عوده كيف تعتبر
الصمود في سوليدار وبخموت امرا حيويا
بالنسبه لها
تنديدا بما شانق المحتاجين وقمعهم في
ايران سبع دول اوروبيه تستدعي ممثلي طهران
لديها
[موسيقى]
بعرض ماليه لمره واحده للممرضين صنعت يسعى
لاخراج القطاع الصحيح البريطاني من غرفه
الانعاش
وفي الولايات المتحده رئيس مجلس النواب
يتوعد بايديا بالمحاسبه بعد زياره الاخير
للحدود المكسيكيه
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من اسخن نقطه في العالم
الحرب في شرقي اوكرانيا حيث تدور معارك
محتدمه على محور مخمط كذلك الامر داخل
سوليدار الاستراتيجيه والتي تشهد قتال
شوارع كيافو عبر مسؤولين عسكريين تعتبروا
الصمود في سوليدار وبخمت امرا حيويه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا للحفاظ على حائطها
الدفاعيه الذي يحمي
سلوفيانوس وهما مدينتان رئيسيتان في منطقه
دومباز شرقيه اوكرانيا ولا تزلان تحت
سيطرتك اما الدفاع الروسيه فاعلنت عن
اسقاط مقاتلتين اوامر وحيه لسلاح الجو
الاوكراني على محوري دنيا
قبل ذلك اعلن انفصالي دنياسقي السيطره على
بلده بخماسك الواقعه بالقرب من سوليدار
شمال شرقي باخمود وتعتبر بلده بخماس مركز
نقل استراتيجي هام لتزويد تجمع قوات
الاوكرانيه في دومباس حيث تمر عبر هذه
المدينه شبكه من الطرق والسكك الحديديه في
وقت تجري معارك شرسه بهدف فرد السيطره على
باخ متواصل لدار في المقابل اعلنتياز ان
وضع الجنود الاكرانيين صعب للغايه مع
استشهاد القوات الروسيه على خط المواجهه
بالقرب من بلده فالدار المتنازع عليها
بشده وفقا ما اعلنت هنا ابنه وزير الدفاع
عن اوكلاني
القوات الروسيه تواصل
والحاقه الخسائر بسفوف القوات الاوكرانيه
على خط التماس في سياق القتال المضاد
البطاريه في دونيتك تم تدمير محطه ايرادار
امريكيه الصنع وايضا تدمير نظام
الغربيه
الى اوكرانيا بالتعاونيه مع دول الغربيه
اخرى وبحسب الاذاعه البولنديه فقط ارسلت
السلطات البولنديه اكثر من 200 دبابه من
تراستاذن وعشرات من عربات القتاليه الى
اوكرانيا وتوقعت بولندا استلام دبابات
ليوبار الالمانيه حيث يمتلك الجيش
البولندي 126 دبابه من طراز تو ايفون
105 دبابات من طراز تو اي 5 من جهاتها
اعلنت المانيا انها لا تستبعد التسليم
دبابات ليوبال وهي مركبات قتاليه اثقل من
مركبات
لدعم القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
المستقبل كما تدرس بريطانيا تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات لاول مره بعد ما كانت
المناقشات جاريه لضعت اسابيع حول تسليم
دبابات القتال الرئيسيه تشالنجر
السابعه للجيش البريطاني
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب من دونياسك
رائد الاخبار مراسل العربيه رائد يعني
بعدما عاده الامور الى المربع الاول بين
الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني كيف هي الصوره
من هناك وسط الحصار المفروض على المنطقه
ليال بالفعل عادت المعارك الى سابق عهدها
هناك قصف متبادل وعنيف وشرس ما بين
الطرفين مازلنا نسمع ذوي الانفجارات هنا
في مدينه دانيت كما ان يعني اصوات القصف
المدفعي وبرجم وبراجمات الصواريخ من قبل
روسيا ايضا عنيف جدا ويعني بالمقارنه
القصف الروسي هو اكثر بعده اضعاف من القصف
الاوكراني ومعارك ضاريه تدور في عده محاور
من المقاطعه الجنوبيه والشماليه والشماليه
الغربيه بالقرب
يعني طقوم المدينه ماري كواف كربونات تقدم
لان قوات المواليه لروسيا خاصه في ماريكا
من السيطره الكامل عليها لصالح روسيا اما
المحور الاهم وهو كما اسلفت الى اكثر
سخونه ربما في العالم فهو محور ومحيط همم
اخر الاخبار ان الطريقه السريعه الذي يوصل
من مدينه باخموت الى سوليدار التي تشهد
معارك وقتالات في الشوارع ما بين قوات
بالنار الخاصه وما بين الجيش الاوروني
المتمركز والذي ما زال يدافع عن الذين
يعني قصفت همم الدفاعات عفوا القوات
الروسيه بالمدفعيه وبراجمات الصواريخ
الامدادات العسكريه على الطريق السريع ما
بين
سوريا
اوكراني تم تنحياتهم قبل ساعات في هذا
المحور ايضا تقول يعني المصادر من ارض
المعارك هناك بان همم القوات الخاصه
الشيشانيه وقوات بالنار معا سيطرت على
اطراف المدينه حيث ثلاث بلدات
الجيش الروسي بشكل عام فيدراليه يتقدم من
المحور الشمالي ويحاول الصيدره السيطره
على بلده سندار وساعده بذلك حسب
متابعين للملف عن قرب همم هو قصف المقر
همم يعني المقر الاتصالات مقر مقر القياده
التي يتواصل مع قمر صناعي صارلي
ويعمل على التواصل ما بين
قياده العمليات هو المقاتلين في الجباءات
القوات الروسيه قامت بقصف صاروخي لهذا
المقر وقطعت الاتصالات ما بين الجبهه ما
بين المقاتلين على الجبهات من القران وما
بين القياده وهذا ما يساعد القوات الروسيه
الخاصه
خاصه بتقدم في ال سيطره على سندار التي
يمكن ان يسيطر عليها الجيش
رائد يعني الجيش الاوكراني للانسحاب من
الناحيه الغربيه هل هو تكتيك ناجح حتى
الساعه ما الذي يمكن ان ينتج عنه بالساعات
المقبله
الروسيه منذ ان بدات كانت تعتمد يعني
استراتيجيه قدم الاراضي وهي الان تعود
لتلك الاستراتيجيه القديمه بقدم الاراضي
حيث انها بدات تقدم الاراضي نحو مدينه
باخمود عبر البلدات بلده البلده ومن ثم
الى سليدار ومن ثم التقدم بالاحياء ومن تم
دفع الجيش الاسرائيلي الى الانسحاب لا نظر
للجيش
الخبراء هنا لان
التطوير الروسي الكبير القصب المدفعيه
والصواريخ اكثر من عميد على الانسحاب
للحفاظ على اروعهم على الاقل شكرا
بعد ما يقرب العام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
تقترب الحرب هناك اكثر فاكثر من استخدام
الروبوتات القاتله لحسم المعركه وفقا طبعا
لخبراء عسكريين تحدثوا لي السوشيت بلاس
الروبوتات القتاليه تاسس
لثوره عميقه في التكنولوجيا العسكريه ما
يجعل الحروب اكثر دمويه لانها تقضي على
البشر
وتجعل التحكم في العمليات اكثر وتستند الى
احداثيات وتحليلات سابقه للعمليات
الهجوميه المحتمله ولكن ماذا عن هذا الخطا
هذا الهامش يظل كبيرا وهو ما يدفع الخبراء
العسكريين للدعوه الى تقييد العمليات
الهجوميه المعتمده على الذكاء الاصطناعي
تقدم الطائرات المسيره في اوكرانيا وتتقدم
من الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني مما ادى
الى تسريع الاتجاه التكنولوجي الذي طال
انتظاره حيث يمكن ان يجلب قريبا اول
روبوتات قتاليه مستقل كامل في العالم الى
ساحه المعركه ويطلق عصرا جديدا من الحروب
يقول طبعا هنا الخبراء ايضا يمكن لي
الطائرات مشاهدينا من دون طيار بالفعل
التعرف على اهداف مثل المركبات والمدرعات
باستخدام الصور المفهرسه كما نشاهد هنا
ولكن الخلاف متواصل حول ما اذا كانت
التكنولوجيا موثوقه بدرجه كافيه لضمان عدم
ارتكاب الالات للخطا والفتك بغير المقاتل
لاكرانيا بالفعل طائرات هجوميه من دون
طيار شبه مستقله واسلحه مضاده للتكنولوجيا
مزوده بالذكاء الاصطناعي الطائرات القاتله
ذاتيه التحكم بالكامل هي خطوه ثانيه
منطقيه وحتميه في تطوير الاسلحه في
اوكرانيا ويمكن طبعا اللجوء اليها في سته
اشهر المقبله كما اكد وزير التحول الرقمي
الاوكراني سابقا بالنسبه لروسيا يعتبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي اولويه حيث اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان من يسيطر على
هذه التكنولوجيا سيحكم العالم
[موسيقى]
في غضون ذلك حظرت تقارير استخباراتيا
بريطانيه من استخدام روسيا اسلحه حديثه
لتعزيز قوتها الناريه في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا ابرز واستخدام طائرات من طراز 57
[موسيقى]
تفرض الحرب في اوكرانيا سيناريوهات جديده
فما استمرار الوصول الشحنات الاسلحه
الغربيه الى اكياس بدات روسيا في استخدام
اسلحه حديثه ومتطوره وادخالها لقوتها
الناريه في ساحه الحرب لاول مره تقرير
لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه اكد ان روسيا
استخدم الطائرات سوخوي 57 المتطوره لاطلاق
الصواريخ بعيده الماده من الاجواء الروسيه
على اهداف اوكرانيا
لكن بما تتميز هذه المقاتله هي من الجيل
الخامس للطائرات الاسرع من الصوت ثنائيه
المحرك دخلت الخدمه لاول مره عام 2020 في
القوات الجوف الفضائيه الروسيه تستخدمها
روسيا في تدمير شبكه الدفاع الجوي في
اوكرانيا
لقبانيتها في تنفيذ مهمه متعدده
اكتشاف الاهداف على مدى اكثر من 400 كيلو
متر قادره على تتبع الستين هدفا في ان
واحد
في خطوه تتخذها موسكو للرد على التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا ابرزه خطط دعمها بمنظومه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه
نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقطات المظهر
استخدام المقاتل الصخوري 57 صاروخ كروز
الموجه تلفزيونيه ضد اهداف عسكريه في كيف
وتدميرها
بدخول الحرب في اوكرانيا عامها الثاني
تسعه اوكرانيا لتقويه دفاعاتها وترسمتها
العسكريه للحفاظ على اراضيها والحد من
التقدم الروسي
الغرب بمواصله الحرب وضخ اسلحه جديده
ويقول ان جلها يفوق التوقعات
[موسيقى]
على وقع الارتفاع وتيره الانتهاكات
واستمرار نصب المشارق بحق المتظاهرين في
ايران ادانت المانيا سياسه الاعدامات هذه
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه اعتبرت ان
النظام الذي يقتل الشباب لترويع الشعب لا
مستقبل له وذلك في اشاره طبعا الى النظام
الايراني مضيفه ان بلادها ستضيف مزيدا من
قاده الحرس الثوري الايراني لقائمه
عقوباتها بريطانيا وفرنسا وقبلها بلجيكا
والنرويج والدنمارك وهولندا هي الاخرى
انتقدت سياسه طهران بشنقه المحتاجين وقررت
استدعاء السفراء وسفراء ايران كذلك كندا
فرضت عقبات على شخصيات ايرانيه مرتبطه
بقمع المحتاجين ورغم كل ذلك لا يزال نظام
يعلق المحتاجين بعد الفاقتهم من بهدف
ارهاب الاحتجاجات وخفضيراتها
الشرطي قتل في مكان اخر حسب موقع الشرطه
نفسه اي انه قتل في مدينه الرباط كريم
ولكن نسبه الى ملف ابني هذا ما ذكره موقع
الشرطه عندما كان الشرطي ملقا على الارض
ركله الناس الا انهم نسبوه الى ملف ابني
حتى يعدموه كما قال الخطيب في يوم تشييع
جثمان القتيل كرمبور بانهم تجمعوا عليه
هنا وقتلوه هنا ما يعني انه قتل خلال
اشتباك وليس نتيجه لدعسه بسياره الجميع
يعلم ذلك لكن تعمدوا ان ينسبوه الى ملف
ابنه ليشنقوه هؤلاء يمارسون الظلمه انهم
ظلمه
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا بعد ما يقارب اربعه اشهر على
او اربع اربعه اشهر على بدا الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه نسج الاطباء شبكه مخيفه لمساعده
جرح الاحتجاجات الذين يتم تعاقبهم في
المستشفيات العامه صحيفه لوفيغاغور
الفرنسيه نقلت عن طبيب ايراني قوله ان
المستشفيات الايرانيه كانت تحت رقابه
مشدده منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات لذلك كان من
المستحيل ان يتوجه المتظاهرون المصابين
الى هناك تجنبا لاعتقالهم من قبل النظام
ويقول الطبيب الذي حول غرفه معيشته الى
غرفه عمليات ان المصابين اغلبهم من الشباب
والنساء وقال طبيب اخر للصحيفه ان القوات
الامن فتحت النار على مئات الاطباء اثناء
التجمع احتجاجه وايضا اثناء التجمعهم امام
مجلس النظام الايراني في اكتوبر الماضي
ويصف الطبيب حاله احد المتظاهرات التي تم
احضارها الى منزله حيث احصى ما لا يقل عن
و80 شظيه من ال- اا في جميع انحاء جسد
الفتاه ووفقا ايضا لشهادات جمعتها الصحيفه
من جميع انحاء البلاد فان عناصر النظام
يستهدفون عمدا اجزاء حساسه من الجسم وعلى
وجه الخصوص الوجه واسفل البطن والساقين
هذا وتمكنت قوات الامن من اعتقال العديد
من الاطباء بينهم ايمان نافابي وهو جراح
من بلده سلندرش التركي الكرديه عفوا كان
يساعد الجرح سرا بعدما نشر هذا الفيديو
الذي يظهره بجوار سرير احد المتظاهرين وهو
يكلمه بعد مقام بمداواته كما نشاهده هنا
[موسيقى]
جدا جدا
اهو مجددا تحالفوا مع الشيطان لتشويه
سمعتي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بسبب تقلب الاسواق
الماليه العالميه والاوضاع الاقتصاديه
الصعبه بانج كولمان سكس الامريكي يتجه الى
الاستغناء عن اكثر من ثلاثه الاف ومئتين
وظيفه في عمليه تعد من اعماق واكبر عمليات
التسريح التي قام بها البنك في تاريخه
الحديث وفق ما كشفت طبعا مجموعه جولدن
رفضت التعليق على الموضوع ولكن صحيفه
الامريكيه اكدت الامر مشيره الى ان عمليات
التسريح ستحصل في غضون ايام وستؤثر على
معظم الاقسام الرئيسيه للبنوك ومن المتوقع
ان تركز على قسم الخدمات المصرفيه
الاستثماريه والتخفيضات ستمثل نحو
6.5% من القوى العامله البالغ عددها تسعه
واربعين الفا وهي اقل من سيناريو الاسوء
المتمثل بثلاثه الاف 900 وظيفه
[موسيقى]
وبالحديث عن الازمات الاسود لم ياتي بعد
والعام 2023 قد يكون احد اكثر الاعوام
تحديا منذ عقود لان المشهد العالمي يظل
اكثر تقلبا وغموضا من اي وقت مضى في
التاريخ الحديث تقول هنا مجلات ذا ناشونا
الانترست الامريكيه التي سردت بالتفصيل
اخطار العام الحالي المجله تحدثت عن حاله
الركود التي وقعت في المملكه المتحده
ورجحت ان يكون الركود في الولايات المتحده
اقصر واقل مما هو عليه في اوروبا التي
تتعرض للضغوط بسبب قربها الجغرافيا من
الصراع في اوكرانيا واعتمادها التقليديه
على الطاقه بشكل مباشر من روسيا اما احوال
الصين بمجرد ان تتكيف مع كورونا خلال عام
20320 سوف ينتعش اقتصادها من جديد
الاقتصاد الصيني ربما ايضا يؤدي الى
ارتفاع التضخم في الاقتصادات الغربيه طبعا
بحسب المجله بسبب تدهور الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا والمرجحه ان تزداد سوءا في
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله كون روسيا تستعد
لشان هجوم كبير في النصف الاول من عام
2023 بعدما جندت اكثر من 200,000 شخص جديد
في الاشهر التي سبقت نهايه العام 2022 اما
الديون المتساعده في الاسواق الناشئه
فاصبحت غير مستدامه الى حد كبير ودول عده
ربما تتعثر خلال عام 2023 فتحصل اسره ذلك
سلسله من حالات التخلف عن سداد الديون
السياديه لا سيما طبعا في افريقيا ما لم
تطلق جهود اعاده او تطلق جهود اعاده هيكله
منسقه وفعاله المجال الامريكيه اعتبرت انه
خلال العام 2023 ستظل التوترات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين مرتفعه بشكل خطير
على جبهات عده لا سيما حول تايوان وبحر
الصين الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من باريس دكتور
دانيال يعني اليوم مستوى البطاله من
المعروف انه الادنى في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده تقريبا ما يحصل من يعني
من تسريب للعمال بعدد من القطاعات
الامريكيه متى يمكن ان يبدا انعكاسه
بالظهور على المؤشرات والارقام
تحيه لك يا سيدتي والمشرين الكرام اعتقد
ان ان ال ال السوق العمل بدا يهتزنا عنا
وهذا ما ظهر في تقرير البطاله الاسبوع
الماضي اعتقد ان التقرير في الواقع
التقرير البطاله في اي دوله هو عمليا هو
مؤشر سابق لمرحله سابقا نحن ننظر الى بعض
المؤشرات ليد تعطي عمليا النظر على الفتره
المستقبليه عندما ننظر عمليا الى النشاط
الى مؤشر نشاط الصناعي ومؤشر نشاط الخدمات
في تراجع كبير عندما نظر الى الكتله
النقديه
الموجوده في الاسواق وانخفاضها بشكل حاد
هذا يعني عمليا ان القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين القدره الشرعيه لدى الشركات
القدره الشركات على الاستدانه والاستثمار
سوف تنخفض كبيرا وبالتالي عمليا نحن نتجه
الى مرحله من ضعف الانشطه الاقتصاديه
وبالتالي
الخاسر الاول سيكون سوق العمل وبالتالي
هذه هي استراتيجيات الفيراري لانه وهي
استراتيجيه الفيدريل الامريكي اللي خفض
التضخم واحتواء التضخم في عمليه ضرب سوق
العمل وبالتالي هذه هي يعني اليوم
امريكا عبر رفع اسعار الفائده همم ما زالت
مستمره رفع اسعار الفائده يعني ايضا زياده
التكاليف على الشركات مما يعني تسريح مزيد
من العمال وبالتالي مزيد من التاثير على
اسواق العمل هذه يعني الدوامه كيف يمكن ان
تنعكس على اسواق العمل على الاقتصاد
العالمي
على الاقتصاد الامريكي نحن اليوم
استراتيجيات الفيدراليه ووضع اسعار
الفائده فوق مستوى الكره انفيشن او التضخم
الاساسي هي 50.25 وبالتالي الامريكي يقول
انه سوف يستمر الى ما نهايه ال 2023 خلال
في هذه الاستراتيجيه الاسواق تقول لا ان
التضخم سوف ينخفض بشكل كبير خلال الفصل
الثاني وبالتالي سوف ينعكس هذا عمليا الى
خفض اسعار الفائده ولكن عمليا ماذا يحدث
بالضبط
بما يحدث اليوم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه القدره الشرعيه للمواطنين بدات
تنخفض بشكل كبير وبدا نوعا ما الاستهلاك
صحيح انه يرتفع ولكن الادخار ينخفض وهذا
يعني انه عمليا بدات تتاكل القدره الشرعيه
بشكل كبير اليوم الشركات ليس لديها القدره
عمليا للاستثمار وخاصه انقطاع البكور
بقطاع البنوك اليوم نشهد ان احنا ارتفاع
لاسعار الفائده بشكل سريع جدا وهذه المره
الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده الذي
يرتفع فيها اصحاب ترتفع فيها اسعار
الفائده بشكل سريع ما معنى ان عمليا
الاحتياطي
اللازم عمليا للمخاطر لهذا البلوغ ترتفع
بشكل كبير وهذا ما يؤدي الى انخفاض
الارباح بشكل هيكل لهذه البنوك وبالتالي
نشهد هذه التسريحات واضيف الى ذلك الشركات
بنفس الحال لذلك عمليا نحن متجهين في
الولايات المتحده الى مرحله نوعا ما الى
اليوم لا تزال اقل سوءا ولكن اي من اين
تزداد سوء هذه المرحله عندما تمتاز الركود
بازمه ماليه طالما ان الركود لم ينتج
بازمه ماليه سوف تبقى الامور نوعا ما
محموله اما اذا حدث ازمه ماليه مواكبه
للركود سوف تزداد الامور سوءا كما هتشهدت
بريطانيا عند ازمه همم ليستراس الاخيره
همم دكتور يعني كل التصريحات للمسؤولين
الماليين الدوليين منذ بدايه هذه السنه
تتوقع ازمه يعني بالاشهر المقبله او على
الاقل بالتقديرات الماليه لهذه السنه كيف
يمكن ان تنعكس هذه الازمه على الاقتصاد
العالمي هل ممكن ان يكون هناك ايضا يعني
سلسله كما نشهد بالقصاد الامريكي سلسله
تصريح جديد ولكن بشركات خارج الولايات
المتحده
الامريكيه انه يدخل يمكم في ركوب تكوني
الى الان ما هو محتمل في اوروبا هناك ركود
اصبحت نوعا ما على الرغم ان هناك الصين
بدا تفتح من من جديد ولكن عمليا ما يحدث
اليوم سوف نشهد سته اشهر الى سبعه اشهر
سوف تقوم من الصعوبه بمكان ان ينهض بها
الاقتصاد الصيني كل هذه المعطيات تدل الى
تباط النشاط اليوم الامطار تتجه عمليا الى
الدول الناشئه عمليا الدول الناشئه لا
يمكن التعاطي معها كما كانت تعاطي في
السابق اللي هي كابلوك واحد اليوم مثلا
البرازيل الهند الفلبين هناك بعض الدول
كالمملكه العربيه السعوديه بدا تعطي
مؤشرات مؤشرات ايجابيه جدا ليسا ما كانت
في السابق وهذه الدول لديها اليوم
الامكانيات الاستمرار هناك بعض الدول التي
يمكن مثلا دول في افريقيا او دول العالم
الثالث سوف عمليا تعاني بسببين السبب
الاول اذا استمر هو ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
من جديد واستفاء ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائيه او في يؤدي الى استنفاذ قدراتها
هذا بالاضافه الى عمليه صعوبه دخول هذه
الدول الى الاسواق الماليه لاستدانا من
جديد نظرا لارتفاع مخاطر هذه الدول شكرا
لكم ميزانيه
[موسيقى]
بهدف اخراج قطاع الصحفي المملكه المتحده
من غرفه الانعاش يدرس رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه رشي صناعه تقديم دفعه ماليه
لمره واحده فقط للممرضين وموظفي الاسعاف
لانهاء الاضطرابات التي تسبب اضطرابا
كبيرا في مؤسسات الان اتش اس خطوه هناك
همم اعتبرت بان صحه تعبير
ببثت التفاؤل بشان انهاء الاضراب اولا وحل
الازمه لكن ما خرج من الاجتماع بين
الحكومه البريطانيه وقاده النقابات في
قطاعات الصحه والتعليم وسكاك الحديد كان
تقدما طفيفا فيما اعتبره واعتبرته نقابه
الممرضين بالمخيب للامال بانتظار ان
تستكمل بقيه المحادثات على امل طبعا
التوصل لحال اوروبا الحكومه والمضربين معا
وهو ما لم يستبعده المفاوضون في المرحله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
اجتماع طال انتظاره بين وزير الصحه
استقبالي ومسؤولي نقابه الصحه لحل النزاع
اضرابات اعضائها بسبب الاجور اجتماع حمل
امال التجنب المزيد من الاضطرابات في
خدمات الصحه الوطنيه التي تعاني من ضغط
شديد غير مسبوق وسط التكهن بسداد دفعه
نقديه لمره واحده الى المطربين ترتبط
بالانتاجيه
ان المحادثات جاريه وفيما يتعلق بالدفع
يجب ان يجري تلك المحادثات على اساس ما هو
في متناول الجميع وما هو معقول
لكن يبدو ان هذه المفاوضات تعثرت في اول
اجتماع بين الطرفين بحسب مسؤول النقابه
لانهاء موجه الاضرابات
الحكومه فرصه اخرى لتصحيح هذا الامر لقد
جئنا الى هنا بحسن نيه ما يريدون التحدث
عنه والانتاجيه عندما يعمل اعضاءنا لمده
18 ساعه كيف يمكنك ان تصبح اكثر انتاجيه
لا اعرف
شهر يناير عاده ما تكون فيه خدمات الصحه
الوطنيه تحت ضغط كبير بسبب الامراض
الشتويه المتزايده الى جانب معالجه
الامراض الاخرى خصوصا ان قطاع الصحه بحاجه
الى ملئ اكثر من 130,000 وظيفه فيما اعلنت
وزاره الصحه انها ستنقل الاف المرضى الى
دور الرعايه لتوفير المزيد من الاسره في
المستشفيات
فشل المفاوضه بين الحكومه والنقابه يعيد
جدوله اضراباته في قطاع الصحه بدءا من هذا
الاسبوع وقد تكون الاكبر على الاطلاق التي
تشهده بريطانيا وفقا النقابه اذا لم يحصل
اعضائها على زياده اجرهم تعكس غلاء
المعيشه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
وايضا يبقى معنا مصطفى زارو من لندن مراسل
العربيه مصطفى يعني تابعنا بالتقرير
تفاصيل الخلاف اليوم بين نقابه الممرضين
والحكومه البريطانيه ما الذي يمكن ان يكسر
يعني هذا يعني الشقاء الحاصل بين الطرفين
خصوصا وان هناك اسرار من قبلهم على اخذ
هذه الزوجه او العلاوه
يجب الاشاره بان ولو ان لم تخرج هذه
المفاوضات اليوم بنتائج من موسى الا انها
تعتبر
خطوه ايجابيه في الاتجاه الصحيح لحل
النزاع مع النقابه والحكومه وبالتالي
يقولون بان ربما ستكون هناك المزيد من
الاجتماعات الحكومه لمحاوله ايجاد حل لهذه
الخلاف بين اعضاء النقابه والحكومه بالطبع
الحديث عن دفع علاوه او مبلغ مالي مثل ما
شهيدناه همم قامت به
قام به المسؤولون في الصحه في مقاطعه ويلز
كان هناك حديث في اروقه همم الحكومه بان
تريد ان تقدم الى همم يعني تقريبا وان
ستكون ربما اعلى بكثير مما تم تقدمهم
اولئك الذين يعملون في المستشفى لكن هذه
همم العلاوه ربما يعني لقيت همم خيبه امل
من بعض ممثلي النقابات لانها همم ربما تم
التركيز اكثر على عمل همم يعني افراد همم
الاطقم المتنوعه لدخل المستشفيات بدل من
الحديث عن هذه الاجور رفع الاجور او تقديم
هذه الدفعه النقديه بحسب نقابه يونس تقول
بانه تم اا ال- ال- المناقشه الاجور ولكن
لم يتم تقديم تنازلات ملموسه من قبل
الحكومه من شانها ان همم تمكن من الغاء
الاضطرابات المرتقده هذا الاسبوع بالتالي
الذي ضربات مجدوله هناك هناك يومين
لاضراب اطقم الاسعاف او اول اضراب سيكون
يوم الاربعاء ومن ثم في الثامن عشر في 23
عفوا في الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر
بالاضافه الى ان
همم اضراب الممرضين سيكون ليومين متتاليين
في الثامن عشر وال19 وبالتالي همم يعني
تخشى السلطات الصحه هذا الاضراب الذي قد
يؤثر على همم على المرضى واولئك الذين
يريدون ان ان ان ان يعني يذهبوا الى
المستشفيات للطرقي مختلف العلاجات
وبالتالي هذا مقلق للغايه ولكن يبدو انه
هناك نيه لمحاوله ايجاد حل لهذه المعذره
بين النقابه والحكومه لرفع الاجور بالتالي
ربما ننتظر المزيد من المفاوضات بين
الجانبين همم مصطفى يعني من المعلوم انا
المشكله الاجور هي مشكله مشتركه بين جماعه
الفئات العامله هناك وسط التضخم وتاكل
القدره الشرائيه همم يعني الوصول الى
تسويه مع الممرضين والحصول على دفعه
الممكن ان تنسحب على دفعات اخرى وهل
باستطاعات الحكومه القيام بذلك
تقول الحكومه ان اي تسويه يجب ان تكون في
مداوله الجميع وتكون معقوله يعني بان ربما
الحكومه لن ترفع هذه الاجور بنسب تتجاوز
نسبه الفائده حاليا كان هناك حديث بانه
يجب ان تكون هذه الزياده في حدود 19% ومن
ثم ربما هناك تراجع من قبل النقابه ربما
على الاقل يجب ان تكون في حدود ال 10%
يعني حاليا همم نسبه التضخميه قرابه 11%
ولكن تقول الحكومه بان رفع الاجور بهذه
النسبه ربما سيازي يزيد من التضخم يزيد من
معاناه الجميع ليس فقط ولكن الذي يعملون
في قطاع الصحه وبالتالي المفاوضات ستتواصل
ولكن الاضطرابات همم تنفذ وربما يعني
المزيد من هذه بسبب لارام الحكومه لتقديم
تنازلات ملموسه ووقف هذا الصراع الذي يشل
مختلف لسه فقط قطاع الصحه بل ايضا في قطاع
همم النقل خاصه همم في سكك الحديد
بالاضافه الى ان التعليم ايضا يواجهها
ازمات واضرابات متوقعه نحن مقبلون على على
المزيد من هذه الاضطرابات ان لم يتم
التوصل الى حل لوقتها شكرا لك يا مصطفى
زاهر ومراسل العربيه حدثنا من لندن
في بريطانيا ايضا كشفت صحيفه كبيره من
البريطانيين تخلوا عن جنسيتهم منذ خروج
المملكه المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
الامير هاري لم يرفع بعد كل يعني الزناد
بعد عدا مجددا ليتهم عائلته الملكيه
بالتحالف مع الشيطان لتشويه سمعه وفقه
وصفهاري الذي اطلق حملته التسويقيه لكتاب
مذكراته اسباب
المقابله على ان عائلته وخاصه زوجه ابيه
كامله تسرب قصص سلبيا للصحافه عنه وعن
زوجته
وانتقد هاري بشكل متكرر اخيه ووالده
وقتهامهما بانهما اجبرهم وميغان ماركل على
الابتعاد عن البلاد وكشف ان شقيقه ويليام
اصر عليه ان يحلق لحيته قبل زفافه وهو ما
رفضه الامير القيام به وفي اول سلسله من
المقابلات التلفزيونيه التي بثت قبل نشر
مذكراته اتهم رايه افراد عائلته بالتعاون
مع الشيطان اي الصحافه الصفراء لتحسين
سمعتهم على حساب سمعته هو وزوجته
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل الجائحه
وبدون اي قيود على العمر
[موسيقى]
الحجاج
من اي مكان بالعالم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا وزير الحج والعمره
الدكتور توفيق ربيعه ان حج هذا العام
سيكون بنفس العدد قبل جائحه كورونا مؤكدا
عوده الحج بدون قيود او شروط واوضح وزير
الحج والعمره ان الحج لن يشترط فيها حد
اعلى للعمره
بشارتين
في هذا اللقاء
البشره الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه وبدون اي قيود على العمر
بعثه من اي دوله في العالم عاده ترتبط
بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
وتطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الان وابتداء من
هذا العام اي بعثه الحج اي مكتب حج من اي
مكان في العالم يستطيع التعاقد مع اي شركه
مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات اللي يحتاجها حجاج
هذه الدوله
وبحسب اخر احصائيه رسميه قبل رائحه كورونا
فقد وصل عدد الحجاج لعام 2019 الى نحو
اثنين فاصله خمسه مليون حاج منهم اكثر من
مليون و800 الف حج من خارج السعوديه وكانت
المملكه قد اتخذت اجراءات احترازيه خلصت
بموجبها عدد الحجاج اثناء جائحه كورونا
وفي العام الماضي رفعت الاعداد الى مليون
حاج من داخل السعوديه وخارجها لكنها فرضت
شروطا من بينها الا يكون الحاج قد تجاوز
65 عاما مع الصراط استكمال التحصين لجرعه
الاساسيه بلقحات كورونا
[موسيقى]
تواعد كفن مكارثي الرئيس
بالمحاسبه ردا على زياره الرئيس الامريكي
للحدود مع المكسيك وذلك بعد يومين فقط من
انتخابه رئيسا لمجلس النواب الامريكي رئيس
مجلس النواب وصف زياره بايدن هذه بانها
لاجل التقاط صوره لاجل الدعايه انتخابيه
كون بايدين ينوي الترشح لرئاسه عام 2024
زياره تاتي بين مكانه يضغط من اجل العفو
عن ملايين المهاجرين الذين عبروا الحدود
الى الولايات المتحده بشكل غير قانوني
وفقا لوصفه بكارثه الذي حذر من تداعيات
هذه الزياره قائلا ان الجمهوريين سيحاسبون
بيضا ووزير داخليته في مجلس النواب على
خلق اخطر ازمه حدوديه في التاريخ الامريكي
الجمهوريين الذين باتم يسيطرون على مجلس
النواب تعاهدوا اطلاق سلسله في سبل اداره
كورونا وقرار الانسحاب من افغانستان وقال
مكارثي من مقر مجلس النواب بعد اداءه
اليمين وتنصيبه خلفا للديمقراطيه
ناسيبيلوسي لقد حان الوقت لممارسه رقابه
على سياسه الرئيس الامريكي جوبتا
نزل المواجهه
بين الرئيس الامريكي ومجلس النواب بسبب
زياره الاولى يقوم بها جوبادل للحدود
الجنوبيه التي تعاني من مشكله تدفق
المهاجرين والمخدرات
بتحرك الجمهوريين نحو محاسبه لن تستثني
الرئيس وزير الداخليه في مجلس النواب بسبب
خلق اخطر ازمه حدوديه في التاريخ الامريكي
بحسب تعبيره في وقت يرى فيه بعض
الديمقراطيين ان البلاد تعاني من نقص كبير
في الايدي العامله لجراء قيود صحيه فرضها
دونالد ترامب وتم الاعتراض عليها امام
القضاء
الحدود بين الولايات المتحده والمكسيك
ممتده على ثلاثه الاف ومئه كم على تلك
الحدود تم القاء القبض على رقم قياسي بلغ
مليونين و 200 الف مهاجر العام الماضي
ارسل البيض الى الكونجرس خطه لاصلاح
الهجره في اول يوم له في منصبه لكنها
تعثرت وسط معارضه من الجمهوريين في
الكونغرس الذين منعوا ايضا طلبه للحصول
على ثلاثه مليارات و500 مليون دولار
لتعزيز تطبيق الحدود
يحول الرئيس الامريكي من خلال زيارته تلك
اخماد الضجيج سياسيه وتخفيف التاثير
التحقيقات المقبله في الهجره التي وعد بها
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
الجمهوريون استخدموا باستمرار قضيه الحدود
ضد باين والقو باللوم عليه لفشل في اتخاذ
اجراءات انصارمه
يبدو ان اي حركه للرئيس الامريكي ستكون
تحت عدسه رصد مجلس النواب ذي الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه المعارضه
لن تبدا بازمه الحدود والمهاجرين ولن
تنتهي عندها عصام عبد السلام العربيه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن عبر سكايب الدكتور
فراس مقصد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن استاذ فراس يعني عاده
معتدنا موضوع المهاجرين ان يكون اداه او
ورقه سياسيه استعملها الحزين ضد
بعضهم اليوم كيف يمكن ان يكمل المسار بين
الطرفين خصوصا ما قبل الانتخابات بالسياسه
طبعا
مشكله مزمنه وهي عابره للانقسمات السياسيه
هنا في واشنطن
فالادارات المتعاقبه اذ كان جمهوريه او
الديمقراطيه لم تستطيع ان تحل هذه المشكله
هنالك اكثر من 230,000 همم من يعبر الحدود
شهريا همم تلقي القبض عليهم السلطات
الامريكيه ولكن المشكله هي اكبر من ذلك
لان ماذا تفعل همم يعني السجون مقتضه ليس
هناك اماكن على تقريبا ربع مليون همم من
يعبر الحدود في تاريخ في يعني بطريقه غير
شرعيه شهريه وهذه هي المشكله اللي هم
اعتقد ان اراه لهم طبعا
الجمهوريين سيستعملوا هذا السلاح ضد
الاداره الامريكيه والرئيس غدا
والمتحدث او رئيس البرلمان هو اليوم ضعيف
جدا وهو يعني همم اكثر باالتزاماته لحزبه
جمهوري بمعاقبه همم هذه احدى الطرق التي
سيحاول ان يعاقب ادم بها
دكتور يعني موضوع الهجره بين الحزبين من
المعلوم بانهم معطل بالكونجرس منذ زمن
لانه ملف سياسي بالامتياز برغم من انه
تبعات على الاقتصاد الامريكي تابعات على
الداخل نتحدث عن اكثر من 30 مليون مهاجر
غير شرعي موجودين يعني على الاراضي
الامريكيه اليوم كيف سيكمل المساره
القانوني مع استدعاء مجلس النواب لبعض
المسؤولين عن هذا الملف
نعم شكرا لهذه الاضافه وعليها ايضا ان
اقول ان هنالك افاده لعند الجمهوريين حتى
بموضوع ال ال الهجره غير شرعيه لانه
الكثير من الشركات الكبرى ورجال الاعمال
الذين يصوطون ويساندون الحزب الجمهوري
يعانون من ازمه عدم وجود الموظفين او اليد
العامله وهم يستفيدون من هذا التدفق من
المكسيك من يد العامله الرخيصه من المكسيك
وهنالك يعني ما يسمى فاشل الانترا هنالك
مصالح عندك الى الطرفين كلا الحسبان في
هذا الموضوع المتشعب اما ما يحدث من الان
اعتقد ان كفن كارتي سيعقد الكثير من جلسات
الاستنطاق يعني المحاسبه في الكونغرس
الامريكي ليحاسب او ياتي اذا كان وزير
الداخليه او مسؤولين كبار مسؤولين حراس
الحدود في الولايات المتحده
ليلقي الدواء على هذا الموضوع ولا يكون
هنالك هم روجا اعلاميه يستطيع ان يستفيد
منها طبعا سياسيا اما الحل اعتقد انه
سيكون صعب
نعم شكرا لك دكتور فراس مقصد استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جورج واشنطن
على هذه المدخله
اعتمد الرئيس الامريكي جوبؤيدن اعلان حاله
الطوارئ في كاليفورنيا بسبب عواصف التسببت
في مقتل 12 شخصا على الاقل خلال الايام
العشره الماضيه فيما تسببت العواصف
بالقطاع الكهرباء عن اكثر اكثر من 20000
منزل وشارك في كاليفورنيا بحسب بيانات
موقع ارصاد جويه ومن جانبها اصدرت ولايه
كاليفورنيا اوامر باجلاء تحذير في اجزاء
من شمالي الولايه بسبب العاصفه الشديده
التي ضربت الساحل
[موسيقى]
في البرازيل فكاكات الشرطه البرازيليه
خيامنا في نقطه تجمع رقمها انصار الرئيس
السابق جرير بوسينارو في العاصمه برازيليه
بعد يومين من قيام محتاجين عشان اسوا هجوم
على مؤسسات الدوله منذ عوده الحكم في
البرازيل
الديمقراطي في ثمانينيات القرن الماضي
بينما وبعقاب شديد تعهد الرئيس البرازيلي
دا سيلفا باحاله المتورطين في اعمال العنف
للعداله بعد محطم المتظاهرون النوافذ
والاثاث وجمر اعمالا فنيه وسرقوا بنادق
وقطعا اثريه
[موسيقى]
درجات الحراره المرتفعه بشكل قياسي هذا
الشتاء في اوروبا انعكست ايجابيا حيث خفت
من ازمه الطاقه وتبدو مستقره حتى الان رغم
استمرار العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
فالمانيا تقول ان امدادات الغاز لهذا
الشتاء امنه ويجب التركيز على الشتاء
المقبل بينما تستمر بريطانيا في معاناه
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز وستمر لعمين او ثلاثه
اعوام مقبله
يبدو ان شتاء اوروبا هذا العام الدافئه
بعض الشيء جاء في صالحها فكان الاوروبيون
يخشون لاشهر من التجمد هذا الشتاء بسبب
ازمه طاقه الناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ولم يتوقعوا حينها موجه حاره
العلميه تقول لان 5 10 دوله اوروبيه على
الاقل شهدت درجات حراره قياسيه الاسبوع
الماضي وامتدت لمناطق من فرنسا الى
المانيا وبلجيكا وهولندا
فالعاصمه البولنديه وارسو التي تتمتع بسجل
المناخي يعود تاريخه الى مئه عام حتى مطر
رقم القياسي لدرجه الحراره في يناير باكثر
من خمس درجات مئويه ويعود ذلك بشكل عام
الى ارتفاع حراره الغلاف الجوي والمحيطات
حول العالم المانيا بدورها افادت بان
لديها ما يكفي من الغاز خلال موسم الشتاء
الحالي دون التعرض لخطر امدادات الطوارئ
وفقا منظم الالمانيه كلاوس مولر وان
التركيز ينصب الان على الشتاء القادم
مؤكدا ايضا ان مخزون الغاز في المانيا
تفوق مستوياته حاجزه 90% اما في بريطانيا
رجح الخبراء من انه من غير المتوقع ان
تنخفض فواتير الغاز خلال العامين او
الثلاثه اعوام المقبله على الرغم من
انخفاض اسعار الغاز بالجمله الى مستويات
لم تشهدها منذ ما قبل الازمه الاوكرانيه
انخفاض اسعار الغاز بالجمله لم ينعكس على
الفواتير الاستهلاكيه للافراد حيث يشتري
الموردون الكثيره من الغاز مقدما باسعار
قد تكونوا اعلى من العاده وفقه صحيفه تمر
البريطانيه هذا عدا عن استمرار ارتفاع
اسعار الكهرباء في بريطانيا بثلاث مرات
مقارنه بالغاز الطبيعي ما يجعل حتى
الاجهزه الكهربائيه لتدفئه المنازل وشحن
السيارات باهضه الثمن رشا خياط العربيه
[موسيقى]
كشف الامين العام للنيتو عن استكمال
السويد للمتطلبات الانضمام الى حلف الناتو
بعد صدور موافقه تركي على ذلك ايضا جاء
ذلك بعد ما ابدى رئيس الوزراء السويدي امس
عظمه بلاده الانضمام الى نظام الدفاع
الجوي التابع لنيته والمساهمه بوحده
قتاليه بريه جديده في قدراتها للدفاع
مجلس الامن الدولي بالاجماع على تمديد
اليه تقديم المساعدات الى سوريا عبر تركيا
لمده سته اشهر اخرى ودخلت امس قافله مكونه
من ثمانيه عشره شاحنه الى محيط ادلب عبر
خطوط المواجهه التي تسيطر عليها قوات
النظام السوري فيما تحركت روسيا لاستبدال
المساعدات الانسانيه التي تعبر الحدود
التركيه الى سوريا بقوافل تمر عبر المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها النظام
القرار الذي اعتمدنا اليوم
اضافه الى اهميه توفير الكهرباء للسوريين
والتي تعد من الضرورات الانسانيه
للاثار واحدا من اكثر المواقع التي يقصدها
جمهور الفرق المشاركه في بطوله الخليج
بنسختها ال 25 هذا المتحف يضم 22 قطعه
اثريه لحقب مختلفه
بطوله خليجي بنسختها الخامسه والعشرين
التي تقام في البصره حولت متحف المدينه
للاثار الى واحد من اهم الاماكن التي
تقصدها الجماهير ووسائل الاعلام الخارجيه
التي دخلت المدينه باعداد وصلت الى اكثر
من 35,000
من خلال تواجد هناك اعلاميين اماراتيه في
خليجي 25 الى جانب ان احنا همم نغطي
البطوله من الجانب الرياضي وايضا احنا كان
دورنا ايضا نبرز الحضاره الاسلاميه وايضا
تاريخيه اللي تمتلكها العراق احنا بالبصره
استفادينا من عندك معلم همم للضيوف اللي
اجونا من الخارج الصراحه صار يعني كان
عنوان انه يجون يزورون ويشوفون تاريخ
العراق والتاريخ البلاد الرافدين
هذا المتحف الذي يقع على شط العرب يضم
قطعا اثريه تعود الى الحقب السومريه
والبابليه وصولا الى العصر العباسي
بتواجهه ثقافيه وحضاريه
لتاريخها واعراقتها
الحضاري اكثر من 2200 قطعه اثريه كل
القطعه اللي موجوده في متعه البصره
الحضاري هي قطع اثريه اصليه تعود لفترات
متعدده متحف البصره الحضاري يتوافق اليه
همم العديد من الضيوف
اشقائنا العرب
الخليجيين
اضافه الى شناشيلها واسواقها التراثيه
وكورنيشها يحرس مشجعوا الفرق المشاركه في
بطوله الخليج على زياره متحف البصره
للاثار للتعرف بشكل اكبر على حضاره بلاد
الرافدين وان كان ذلك عبر بوابه كره القدم
من متحف البصره منتظر الرشيد العربيه
وصفه هجوم الروسيه الى عوده افريقيا
[موسيقى]
تستدعي ممثلين
مره واحده
لاخراج القطاع الصحي البريطاني من غرفه
الانعاش
وفي الولايات المتحده رئيس مجلس النواب
يتوعد بايديم بالمحاسبه بعد زياره الاخير
للحدود المكسيكيه
مشاهده التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 وزملاء
راويه وطاهر راويه وطاهر ماذا لديكم
الليله اهلا بك يا ليال سنتحدث طبعا عن ما
حصل امس في البرازيل وتداعيات ذلك
على الطريقه الكوريه نسال ذلك مع طرح بعض
المسؤولين مثل هذا التصور اضافه الى هدف
جديد للامير هاري في كتابه كون معنا